hi everybody thank you for coming and
braving this beautiful 45 degree winter
day to come here we'll talk before we
begin I just want to take the
opportunity to thank C Bay and the GE
colloquium and sustainability leadership
for sponsoring this event and to Susanna
Harris for helping put it together we'll
sarni is currently the director and
practice leader of enterprise water
strategy at Deloitte he's been providing
hydrogeological environmental and
sustainability consulting services to
private and public sector enterprises
for more than three decades with a focus
on developing and implementing corporate
wide sustainability strategies as well
as well as broad-based climate and water
programs wills diverse client list
includes fortune 500 companies
multinationals and NGOs an
internationally recognized thought
leader on sustainability and corporate
water strategies will is a frequent
speaker on the topic and a columnist on
sustainability and water strategies at
Green biz as well as the author of
corporate water strategies and the
forthcoming 21st century growth beyond
the energy water food Nexus will is on
the water leadership working group of
the World Business Council for
sustainable development
he's the Deloitte project lead for the
2013 Carbon Disclosure Project water
program and the Deloitte technical lead
for the CEO mandate Water Action hub
project and with that we'll starting
so first of all thank you for the
opportunity to be here I hope you have a
lot of questions I know that Martha
Smith who is here will have lots of
questions because we basically started
our career together not to call you out
but so I'm a hydrogeologist by education
and the bulk of my experience 2/3
roughly of that 30 30 years it's a
little unusual and delight I think
everyone knows is for tax audit finance
risk capabilities but we have a very
large consulting practice and we have a
what a strategy practice because it's a
very important business issue and it
ties in very nicely to our overall
sustainability practice so I hope I get
the point across that you know this is
more than a resource issue it's a
economic growth issue it's a business
continuity issue it's a risk but also a
business opportunity in the scheme of
things in terms of new products services
technologies and so on so I'm going to
provide a little bit of background
information basically why this is
important this is probably not new to
you but when I go talk to companies
about why water matters and why it's
important for their overall business
strategy and their growth I include some
of the background information to really
just get their attention and then we'll
get into the details of you know who's
doing what why you know why I think that
the business-as-usual projections
probably won't hold that will innovate
our way out of this challenge if you
will so with that I'll go through a few
of these slides so the squeeze on water
supply you know really basically what
this is coming down to is increased
competition for finite resources so you
know we talked about the drought if you
will with respect to water but there
really a number of things going on
driven by population growth economic
growth the rise of the middle class who
wants to buy more stuff if you will
changes in dietary habits and so on so
finite resource
is increased demand and a change if you
will in terms of consumption so you know
what we used to talk about climate
change or we still talk about climate
change it's always this projection you
know 10 20 years out this is what's
going to happen you need to be thinking
about your business strategy you need to
be thinking about how climate change
extreme weather events might impact your
business and so on water is really
different water is here and now it's a
current business risk in a current
business opportunity and you know when
really just has to look at what's going
on in California taxes even the state of
Colorado where I'm from all sorts of
interest activity around the
availability of water to support
economic growth or even just to keep
things as is so I'll call your attention
to two reports that I think are really
powerful and really provides some great
insight as to how companies are thinking
about what a risk and how they're
managing that risk and in some cases
actually developing new products and
services so the world economic forum the
folks that put on Davos every year come
out with their Global Risk report in
January it's a great report to read it
really highlights what are the key
global risks to businesses and for the
past several years water has shown up as
one of the top ten in terms of impact
and likelihood so this past January the
report came out the water crisis was
number three and the food crisis was
number eight World Economic Forum likes
the word crisis so you'll see it
throughout the top ten but this really
sort of drives home the point to
business leaders that may not have
historically focused on water but
suddenly realizing that well world
economic forum to use water food extreme
weather events as critical business
issues that they need to pay attention
to and then I don't know how many of you
know the CDP water report at all
basically the CDP group that brought you
the climate change carbon disclosure
project came out with the water
disclosure program what a program now
it's been in place for the past three
years
and basically what they do is they send
out a questionnaire on a voluntary basis
asking companies report on what are
their water risk risks and what are
their business opportunities and two
years ago they sent it out to 300
companies this past year 2013 they sent
it out to a thousand companies and
companies are actually volunteering and
reporting back because investors are
starting to care about the issue so
they're talking about well this is how
much water I'm using across my value
chain my upstream supply chain my direct
operations are in product use this is
where I've seen business disrupted these
are the risks that I'm saying or I'm
developing new products new chemicals to
improve water treatment whatever it may
be so it's really series of great
reports that give you a bit of a
snapshot into how businesses are
thinking about water issues and what a
strategy I think the numbers speak for
themselves in terms of how these
companies responded so the vast majority
of companies recognize that this is a
current or projected risk and they've
been impacted so again it's here and now
there's there's no argument about you
know hypothetically could this happen
so I you know I opened up with the
energy water food Nexus you can't really
go to a conference these days in the
world of sustainability and not hear
this brought up this tension this stress
if you will it's it's fascinating for a
number of reasons ecosystems are not on
this list but they certainly should be
because there's a water requirement
there that's fairly critical but you can
see that you know these three issues if
you will or interconnected it dependent
upon one another food is interesting you
need energy and water for agricultural
production and again if you're going to
get to nine billion people and feed
everybody then you need the energy and
water to support agricultural production
the energy water Nexus more and more
companies are paying attention to that
especially if you're a power utility if
you're in the oil and gas business and
you like fracking shale you need
so again there's this recognition that
all of these three resource issues are
tied together so that you know the magic
part here is okay so we've talked about
the Nexus everyone seems to sort of get
it we talk about it all the time but
what do we do about it and I'll get to
that a little bit later in terms of what
I think we really need to do some of its
borrowed from others and some of it's
just what I've observed key question
here so multinationals that have very
aggressive business growth strategies
how many are from the business school by
the way
okay so go to any company everyone's
projecting growth so how do you really
support that growth if your business
needs agricultural production energy and
water so suddenly these resources now
tie into growth what happens if your
strategy is tied to growth and emerging
markets
some of the maps I'll show that you know
water is a bit of a problem in places
like China and Africa so again
overlaying what your growth plans look
like on top of some of these reek
writable resource issues and how they're
all dependent it really becomes a very
relevant business issue now so this is
another report to look at it's it was
put together by the 2030 Water Resources
Group which is a group of NGOs and
companies working together in a
pre-competitive space to think about
water scarcity issues and how it might
impact their business so under
business-as-usual conditions there's
roughly a 40% shortfall between now and
2030 not a good story at all key thing
here is that business as usual so I
don't really believe in business as
usual I think we're really good about
innovating in terms of new technologies
and new partnerships so you know the key
here is going to be get off that
trajectory and really think differently
about how we manage water and how we're
stewards of water
so this is best done when it's animated
but it's a bit of a snapshot so this is
what the world looked like roughly in
2000 no surprises here red is not good
these are water stress water scarce
areas this is what it's projected to
look like in 2025 so things change quite
a bit
so think about where's your supply chain
where your customers where your direct
operations and do you have enough water
to support your business basically do
you have know if water to grow crops or
to generate power however you want to so
it's it doesn't paint a great picture
again I'm from Colorado so I'm in the
middle of that red blotch in the US and
everything everyone knows what's going
on in California in Texas and even the
state of Colorado right now around water
issues so these are some of the
projections again this is what is
thought to be a reasonable scenario
going forward so how do we take a
different tack I think differently about
water so what is essentially free most
people know what they pay for cable TV
and don't know what they pay for water I
think that's you know pretty much true
throughout the US unfortunately but
what's happening is that what even water
prices are going up and in the u.s.
water prices are going up at twice the
rate of increase globally so that's
significant it's really starting to
become measurable in your profit loss
statement I have a friend who always
said that water is noise on a profit
loss statement which is true it gets
buried it's it's really not meaningful
sure
I think it's mostly the latter yeah it's
you know if you don't invest in
infrastructure at some point you have to
pay for it so that's really driving it
you know depending on where you're
located you know some states
municipality or making those investments
you know public-private partnerships and
and so on so it's a matter of you know
how do you extract transport treat water
that's really what the cost comes in and
we have a lot of infrastructure that
needs repair that's a promising career
option I would suggest yeah this is not
career advice but you know I think if
you want to focus on water you'd have a
full career for decades so anyway so
prices are going up companies are
starting to pay attention to it in
addition to the risk issue in addition
to the opportunity side of the equation
it's suddenly becoming noticeable if you
will and then at the bottom you know
what we're seeing on the public sector
side utilities it's there's this
discussion around conservation synergy
so how do you tie energy efficiency to
water conservation some utilities in
particular in the state of California
are doing pretty well in terms of
linking rebates and efficiency programs
and pricing and so on so people are now
starting to think beyond that Nexus and
and really start to align incentive
programs to change behavior I'm big on
images of reports to read so I've got a
few more here because I think it tells
an interesting story is who's paying
attention to this issue of water so the
one on the left which you of course
can't read this is a great slide because
no one can read it is from the Federal
Reserve Bank in Dallas Texas and it
talks about what our scarcity impacting
economic growth in the state so you know
this talk of the Texas miracle in terms
of aggressive growth you know the
economy
really growing at a pretty good clip for
a number of years well suddenly how does
water scarcity impact economic growth
and the ability to attract businesses
retain businesses and so on so really
what you're seeing is that there's this
increased discussion around the
availability of water and economic
impact not just to multinationals
operating in emerging markets but here
in the US and particular states so this
is a few pages easyread there's another
one that came out by Goldman Sachs
talking about sustainable growth so you
know really raising the question do
companies have enough water to support
their growth and what happens if they
don't and that report really ties in
very nicely to the CDP reports for the
S&P 500 and the global 500 that was
really the theme for both of those which
is do you have enough water to support
your business growth so investors
financial institutions are now paying
attention to this issue and then this
report on the right came out from the US
EPA on the importance of water in the US
economy Canada came out with a report a
couple years ago that basically looked
at water from a balance sheet
perspective in terms of assets and
liability this is also a really great
report and that it really got people
thinking about water a little bit
differently sorry encourage you to take
a look at those of course in all of your
spare time so just focusing on the US a
little bit I'm just going to go through
these quickly this is from the Drought
Monitor comes out monthly it's an
aggregation of data that paints a
picture you know how much water is
available versus demand so this was 2000
2004 2008 2012 not a great picture 2013
on the average didn't look much better
everyone knows what's going on in
California right now and Texas in terms
of availability it's all over the news
so again it tends to sharpen the mind if
you if you will and
ultimately we'll change public policy I
mean it is to some degree right now it's
changing pricing it's changing how
people think about water and allocate
water in a variety of different industry
sectors so this is just a few images
here to overlay things like agricultural
production and water scarcity so this is
wheat production versus the Drought
Monitor map so 32% of wheat producing
countries counties rather in a drought
pretty significant in the US you could
do the same thing roughly with shale gas
so this is you know aqueducts handiwork
in terms of taking a look at where all
the major shale gas formations where
shale gas being produced and where is
water scarcity so you know in a lot of
ways you don't want to be in the west or
the south you might want to be in the
Midwest
all of a sudden where water is a little
bit more abundant
so again just thinking differently about
what is your asset in the ground do you
have enough water to develop that asset
and what we're seeing is that in the
world of water there's more and more
discussion around not just business
disruption and business continuity but
also stranded assets so have you made an
investment but you don't have water to
exploit that reserve whatever it may be
then power production pretty much the
same story here this is from the Union
of Concerned Scientists they came out
with this a while ago so you're starting
to see the thermoelectric power sector
really pay attention to water as a
critical resource for their business
that sector reported through CDP and had
some really good insight in terms of how
they're thinking about what are they
developing a water strategy what are
they doing to mitigate that risk and how
they engaging with stakeholders on the
topic so actually have this conversation
this afternoon in terms of what happens
at first so there's you know physical
scarcity physical risk businesses pay
attention to it and then surely public
policy change
just around the issue and you people are
either saying yes or now so I think
there's some interesting developments
you know so if you look at the state of
Texas California and Arizona public
policy is is really starting to change a
bit there was a two billion dollar fund
that was approved in the state of Texas
last November to fund water projects not
just water supply projects but
conservation projects so the state of
Texas is now paying attention to the
role of water in the state economy and
making investments in new infrastructure
to your question about you know where's
this coming from you know you're
starting to see those discussions
happening in the state of California
right now and even the state of Colorado
were in the way in the process right now
developing a statewide water plan which
would be the first for us and thinking
through what are the implications around
shipping a lot of our water out of state
how do we balance most of the growth on
the eastern slope versus having all the
water on the western slope you know and
what does all that mean
so public policy is starting to change
in response to the reality of how much
water is available I love this image so
this is my segue into well so what our
business is doing really which is where
I spend the bulk of my time so I sit in
our commercial practice and talk to us
multinationals or non US multinationals
all the time about water and how that
fits into their strategy their growth
their risk evaluation and and so on and
there's actually a lot of activity
probably a lot more than you might be
aware of through public disclosure
things like CDP so we talked about what
a risk from a business perspective this
is how we frame it and we talked about
physical risk so do you have enough
water when you need it where you need it
of the right quality and we talked about
regulatory risk so regulations how are
they going to change over time
will prices change over time how might
that impact my business and the
reputationally really critical it's
probably the most difficult to quantify
and put a dollar amount on in some ways
because it can just happen it can shut
down your business you can lose your
social license to operate and you might
have a stranded asset or you might have
an asset that's going to sit there for
some period of time not generating
revenue and then we think about it
across the entire value chain so
upstream supply chain your direct
operations and then product use so for
food and beverage companies obviously
they pay a lot of attention to their own
operations what's going on in their four
walls and a manufacturing facility but
also thinking about their agricultural
supply chain typically that's really the
bulk of water use consumption but also
product use so if you are a company that
makes soap or shampoo you start to think
about well what happens if consumers
don't have access to clean water or
don't have access to water will they buy
my shampoo or soap what do I need to do
to change this is not just a
hypothetical it's a very real issue so
companies in the consumer product sector
are thinking about how to innovate do I
create a shampoo that uses no water very
little water what do I do in terms of
education awareness around these issues
really trying to change behavior in
addition to innovating and new products
and then you can roll all this up into
you know what is the current financial
impact and what might it look like going
forward so really trying to quantify
that value at risk if you will and that
gets you beyond just thinking about the
price of water that gets you thinking
about the value of water to your
business and your growth strategy so
these are the key business questions at
least in my mind you know will you have
access to water in 20 years at any price
so you might want to pay a lot but it
may not be there to support your
business or for consumers or
stakeholders within a watershed and what
you operate in
and then you know obviously the key
question what about growth projections
and you know are they reasonable you
know there's certainly reasonable but
how do you manage that in the face of
increase in competition for water so
you'll probably hear a little bit about
this tomorrow in terms of embedded water
virtual water so you know you can
calculate how much carbon is in a
product you can do the same thing with
water so how much water does it take to
make a cup of coffee or a beer or
whatever it may be and once you start
shipping this around a little bit
you're really importing and exporting
water so there's actually discussion
right now in the state of California
about the AG sector so is water being
exported out of the state when the state
is confronted with this prolonged
drought it's a fair economic question
and what value does it bring to the
state and to the companies that are and
the AG sector you know key takeaway here
is eat the Apple drink the beer
pretty clearly don't eat the steak don't
eat burger but anyway just cuz you feel
for you know basically how people are
thinking about embedded water and some
of the implications so we talked about
the CDP water program again encourage
you to take at least this scan through
it it's you can download it on the
website key thing here is that
institutional investors are now paying
attention to water risk and they have
come together it's over 500 now that
have signed up for the program as of
last year and they're getting
increasingly active in terms of asking
critical business questions around water
as a resource some of the results here
that I gave you a snapshot of this again
most of the company's vast majority of
companies recognize that this is a risk
that they've been exposed to and
impacted by and projected to be impacted
by within the next five years so again
not going away it's here now and then
risks have gone up so we've seen over
the past three years of the reporting
program is that
companies are really talking more and
more about actual impacts and how it's
affecting their businesses so one of the
key themes that we brought out in in the
report and the last report in the global
501 was that this notion of water
stewardship was present but it really
wasn't being built out by as many
companies as we thought so if you looked
at what the actions where the companies
were taking with respect to what a risk
they were mostly focused on direct
operations the the far left and if you
go back to the other slide where I
talked about the various dimensions of
risk across your entire value chain you
see that really if you want to manage
your risk and your food and beverage
company and you'd be looking at your
supply chain sure consumer products
company think about product use so you
know we'll see this change in all
likelihood over the next several years
but really right now companies are
really trying to get their arms around
how much water they're using and their
direct operations what sort of risk does
it represent and then really starting to
branch out and think about their entire
value chain and how do we how do they
engage that value chain around the
shared risk and and hopefully shared
opportunity so when we talk about water
we talk about water stewardship and not
management it's very deliberate if
you're talking about management you're
typically thinking about what can I
control within my manufacturing
operations my four walls we want you to
think about water stewardship which is
how our stakeholders engaged on this
issue that care about water care about
how you use water so again value chain
thinking watershed level thinking across
a wide range of stakeholders that's
really how you get to stewardship and
that's really how you are in a better
position to manage risk if you just want
to drive efficiency and reuse within
your four walls you'll only go so far so
this is a a framework that we put
together it's basically how we think
about what our stewardship there are all
sorts of frameworks out there by the
Alliance for water stewards
[ __ ] or water mandate and other
consulting firms of course but you can
sort of boil it down to three major
categories and we have examples here and
you'll see two of these companies here
tomorrow talking about their water
stewardship program they will talk about
stewardship they won't talk about
management and it's about preservation
so conservation it is about engagement
so that engagement around stakeholders
and your entire value chain and it's
about innovation technology innovation
and partnership innovation and I believe
that the partnership innovation is
really really exciting because you're
getting all sorts of stakeholders even
competitors come together in a
pre-competitive space to figure out how
does everyone have water because if one
company doesn't have water the other one
does that's really not a solution if
you're in the same watershed so there's
a different way of thinking about water
that I think is really encouraging and
then a few examples of how companies
sort of fitness spectrum it's not meant
to be all-encompassing but there's some
really pretty cool things going on in
the world of water in terms of
innovation and thinking about
stakeholder engagement and partnerships
a couple of examples again you'll see
Gregg tomorrow from the coca-cola
company talking about water stewardship
they're a global replenished program how
they think about water how they engage
with stakeholders and basically what
they're doing to address this critical
resource issue so a few examples and
then Nestle they frame this as creating
shared value they believe that water is
key to their their growth their strategy
and they have a framework for
integrating water into their business
thinking so there's no shortage of
actions that companies can take bit of a
laundry list here one size does not fit
all so you need to think about what's
your business strategy overall
where you're going to play globally and
then which actions fall into that
overall stewardship strategy how do you
transfer technology into your supply
chain for example that's something
that's innovative that companies are
investing in innovative partnerships
again I think the partnership story
around innovation is really cool so
you're getting folks teaming together to
address what a risk and develop new
products and services or increase
awareness around water related issues so
again just a few examples a number of
NGOs are listed here also which is
another thing that you're saying it
which is multinationals identifying NGOs
that can put boots on the ground I can
bring a certain talent capabilities to
their water stewardship strategies so
collective action tools that's the term
of art we talk about collaboration but
it's really collective action in the
world of water a couple of things coming
out of the CEO water mandate I don't
know if you're familiar with the mandate
but it's a collection of about 80
companies that have basically signed up
and said what is important to our
business we're going to pay attention to
it we're going to develop mitigation
strategies and we're going to
collaborate together and they put
together a guidance document on
collective action practices so what are
the best practices case studies what
works what doesn't work how do we
essentially play well together and then
on the right they built something called
the Water Action hub so collaboration on
water issues historically has been
pretty ad hoc so what the mandate wanted
to do was build this online
collaboration tool essentially where
stakeholders within a particular
watershed could come together they could
post where they're operating types of
projects they might want to invest in
and partner on whether its efficiency
conservation and so on so it's starting
to add rigor to essentially putting
stakeholders together to come up with
common solutions it's it's been
incredibly powerful it grew from three
watersheds I think it's up to seven
right now so again you can go online and
take a peek and play around with it a
little bit
as I mentioned companies are working
with NGOs wide range of NGOs out there
addressing access to clean water
sanitation and hygiene the varying parts
of the world and and varying focus areas
so companies are partnering with one or
more NGOs it's part of their overall
strategy and I want to go through this
quickly so we have time for Q a common
risk tools this is in no way
comprehensive their tool two of them
here WRI built aqueduct again it's
available online and WWF built the water
risk filter a little bit different in
terms of what they focus on we see a lot
of companies using multiple tools
because they get different information
from using these different tools so if
you really want to think about what a
risk and how to mitigate risk you use as
many tools as you think are appropriate
and you come up with a more
sophisticated strategy going forward
this is an interesting development we're
seeing companies start to think about
access to clean water sanitation and
hygiene as part of their overall
strategy so you know historically this
is a set of externalities that companies
you know didn't pay attention to because
they didn't have to but suddenly you
know we're Freight who are faced with
roughly two and a half billion people
that don't have access to sanitation and
hygiene and I think well over a billion
people they don't have access to clean
water so that's a real problem and this
was put together by the World Business
Council for sustainable development they
basically launched a pledge and a
guideline document trying to get
companies to sign up and say this is
important for a variety of different
reasons and we're going to pick not only
pay attention to but we're going to
invest in it so again I think it's a
really interesting development over the
past year plus and then I'll go through
this quickly so there's really this
paradigm shift of you know we use water
once and we throw it away to the right
which is on a diversify where I get
water from
and I want to be really efficient how I
use it I want to use it over and over
again as much as I can I want to keep
treating it reuse recycling driven by
conservation and efficiency so how do we
get from the left to the right is really
kind of what's going on right now not
just in the private sector but the
public sector this is a big market this
is information from 2012 but it's a
pretty big market opportunity globally
and in the u.s. so you're starting to
see companies investors pay attention to
this
so going from clean tech to water tech
represents again a business opportunity
for a variety of industry sectors and
investors technology opportunities you
know we talk about efficiency and smart
metering those are pretty obvious I
think there's some really interesting
developments in things that are maybe
not so exciting like data acquisition
analytics and visualization tools so
where's the water data can I get it on a
real-time basis so I know what it means
how do I make business decisions on the
fly essentially so you know I think
there's a lot of innovation
opportunities in data everyone talks
about Desalle or treatment technologies
and membrane technologies which are all
really important but data driving
precision agriculture smart agriculture
is increasingly important so treatment
wastewater sludge resource recovery is
big and this is the equipment market
again somewhat out of date but it's
growing and then I think this is almost
my last slide so you know in thinking
about how do you boil all this down so
how do you start to think about well
what are the solutions what do we really
need to focus on and create some simple
construct if you will so this is a work
in progress but I think it's about
collective action and I'm really
interested in your feedback on this
it'll shape how I finalize it but
collective action so stakeholders across
the value chain how do you create
platforms to come
together solve problems around a shared
resource resource productivity so how do
you do more with less or how do you do
anything without essentially that's what
it comes down to connectivity so Big
Data remote sensing machine to machine
communication so how do you really use
data that information piece to act on a
real-time basis I think that's key and
then of course my favorite public policy
this has to change and it is changing so
I think these are sort of the four
buckets and a few examples of how do you
really address that Nexus that
everyone's talking about so we don't
follow that business-as-usual scenario
where we've got a forty percent short
fall so with that this is my most
important slide please take the next 15
minutes to read oh I think I blew
through a lot of info or commentary
really quickly so I hope you have really
challenging questions I know Martha does
because it's payback so thanks and
hey we've about 15 minutes for questions
and bring them so this is gonna yeah
here it comes
yeah name and affiliation and we have
two microphones I'm just wondering if
there's you've alluded to this but I'm
just wondering how the resolution is
good but also how do they reconcile it
as a public community good in terms of
like a community that same business
comes into community its water Shore in
the developing country how much do they
yeah it's a great question so you know
the UN came out with this you know human
right to water declaration a few years
ago so companies have signed up for that
they've basically acknowledged that
there is a human right to water it's not
solely a business issue and I think it's
worth looking at which companies
acknowledge that and balance that
against their their growth strategies
and their stewardship strategies and so
on but to really get to your question I
think you're seeing companies develop
strategies to address that very issue
through collective action initiative so
you know the public sector is civil
society being a very critical part of
how companies build a strategy in a
particular watershed so all these folks
are now at the table so WWF has
something called the water futures
partnership which brings together you
know civil society and businesses and
NGOs to build capacity talk about policy
and pricing and so on so I think that's
going to be
part of the solution you know every
company is different you know clearly in
terms of how they operate and awareness
around the issue but I think that
collective action piece is going to be
the solution to balancing human right to
water public good with what are the
business issues associated with running
my business and trying to grow that and
employ people within the community that
I dodged that question nicely Martha
thank you
just curious all the measurement of risk
because done we do have these tools
these days but they don't really narrow
down to like quantifiable concrete
numbers so I can see you say I have all
the sites what it was a lot of stress
areas but what does that exactly meaning
to me in terms of business and with that
challenge how would you approach you
know right
that's a real critical question and
challenge if you will so those tools are
great in terms of showing you where
scarcity risk resides what you then need
to do it's almost the so wat you know
great map I got it I'm not in a great
position yeah I reside in all the red
places on the map but what does it mean
you know you get to what does it mean by
thinking about all right I generate so
much my revenue in this region and what
I've seen to date is that there's been
business disruption for this period of
time I can then project that out next 10
or 20 years you know you're building it
on assumptions but you're now tying it
to revenue so business continuity or
business disruption gives you some sense
for
are essentially dollars at risk then you
can start to think about regulatory risk
so I've got compliance frameworks in
place they're probably going to get more
stringent in terms of what equality
requirements or prices are going to go
up we're going to go to a you know
tiered pricing program how might that
impact my business operation what's the
dollar investment I need to make then
reputational risk is is really you know
the challenge so you know what is your
brand worth and how do you protect that
brand and what happens if reputational
risk translates into social license to
operate loss well it all of a sudden
goes from this revenue level to zero
quickly and you can think about that you
can you know look at social media
traffic in a particular region who's
talking about water who's talking about
how you manage water
are you a steward of water do you care
about how I value water or my values
associated with water you know do you
recognize that water has you know
religious and social attributes and
addition to economic attributes so there
are ways to get at it it's not always as
quantifiable as you know you would like
or I might like but companies are
thinking about that
virtual water and how it relates to the
appropriate scale for analyzing water
stewardship issues you mentioned you
kind of want to look at the watershed
level sure so you know what we're seeing
is that companies are talking companies
are quantifying the water footprint of
their product using a couple of
different methodologies there's LCA
methodology out there what a footprint
Network does that so you can start to
think about I'm producing this beer and
it uses so much water if you think about
the entire supply chain and I'm shipping
it out or I'm importing it whatever it
may be and you start to make some you
might make different decisions in terms
of processes and where you source your
materials from and so on I think it
probably has a bigger impact potentially
for governments and states at this point
Tony Allen
at a King's College in the UK is the one
that built the methodology the thinking
around virtual water and the economic
implications of it so they've been a few
companies that have actually gone
through the process and what does water
footprint and I thought a little bit
about implications for their business
I'm not sure that anyone's really done
it at the watershed level though I think
it's it's really a product level at this
point Thanks this is a great photo
really where you can build cities in
places like Phoenix and you can grow
irrigated cropland in deserts do you
think that there's a conversation a
really tough conversation coming about
where we do these things in our country
and around the world and whose
drive that sure another great question
well those conversations are happening
now so I mean we're not going to get rid
of Phoenix or you know whatever but you
know companies pay attention to siting
criteria and you know historically
environmental issues have been part of
the criteria now water availability is
part of the conversation so it's
starting to show up in the business
community as an important component to
business expansion business growth you
know at the the city level you know
there's a fair amount of action in urban
settings right now around water
availability and how to think about a
city within a watershed context and what
that means you know how do you drive
efficiency how do you manage stormwater
runoff big issue so there's this
progress you know at least I view is
progress and that we're having a
conversation you know a few years ago we
we were not and I think you'll see the
states start to pay attention to this
more and more as a competitive advantage
you know do you want to move where
there's a lot of water or you want to
move where there's not much and it's
scarce and expensive
in summation of the timing work in terms
of business plans because we know that
even the sure so you know we what I try
and do is drive that conversation where
I'm asked so it's basically you know
think about what's going on right now
then think about five or ten years out
you know if that's your routine business
cycle and that's not to say don't do
something it is really designed to get
the companies and stakeholders to think
differently so you know if I'm putting a
manufacturing facility in an area that's
yellow or red
well investments in water efficiency and
water reuse might be proven you know if
you thought about just the price of
water you probably couldn't get a good
ROI to make it happen but if you think
about the value to your business and how
it all ties in to your business growth
you get a very I think you get a
different answer so you know don't think
about price think about value and what
has to change
water around has anyone calculated a
true cost of water and if that's been
calculated what would that cost me as it
stands right now for any issues sure so
it's you know what is a local issue so
depends where you located and encourage
you to take a look that World Business
Council for sustainable development wash
guideline document because that gets to
the issue of what is the cost associated
with communities not having access to
sanitation and hygiene you know really
what what's the economic and social
implications and costs associated with
it so you know the conversations the
quantification is going on and it's
coming out of you know NGOs and it's
coming out of business and you know the
public sector also so it's there to
varying degrees all the tools that we've
developed how's that
yeah and thanks for setting me up on
that one
I'll buy you a beer or two so I think
there's some great publicly available
tools out there and not just the two
that I showed you so they're great data
layers great visualization tools but you
have to then take those tools and tailor
it to a particular industry or a
particular company to solve a particular
business issue so can you take the data
sets on Aqueduct and put it on tableau
and run it on your iPad for example you
know can you use that as a sales tool
can you use it to inform your
agricultural supply chain on why what a
conservation is important what would
happen to pricing so all great stuff in
the public domain
so now it's a matter of tailoring it to
a particular use application so I'm
curious when you're in business meeting
on these consulting projects and you
might've started to do the answer this
what you're talking about the
reputational risk but I'm curious what
is the thing that people in those
conversations are most fear in terms of
water risk and what if something that
you don't have an answer
there's a lot of things I don't have the
answers to but yeah well you know I wish
there was a really convenient way to
quantify reputational risk and entire to
you know in forming a business strategy
so you know again we've got case studies
examples out there but how do you get
more rigor around quantifying that
reputational risk and how it impacts
brand value most companies even b2b
companies pay attention to brand value
that is really really important it is a
very large percentage of market cap for
companies you know beyond their tangible
assets so bringing in the stories if you
will of some of the challenges that
companies have had you know drives
change if you will I think we're you
know the world of water was still in the
stage of Education awareness I think CDP
is a really good platform to provide
some insight as to how investors are
thinking about what a risk and some of
the changes that they're trying to drive
with with companies so you know I think
they look at it as essentially two sides
you know what is the potential risk to
this asset this investment and also is
this company position to thrive in a
water scarce world or are they
developing new products that are
innovative you know new membrane
technologies whatever it may be that
will drive their growth so they're
looking at it from really both ends if
you will
institutional investors are doing
a lot right now through platforms like
CDP but also you know VCS are paying a
lot more attention to water tech they've
been a few articles recently about that
in terms of capital actually sure so
companies that recognize that water is
essential for their business and have
been at this for a while more than a
year or two are really thinking at the
watershed level beyond their operations
and what that means is that they are
working in frameworks that give them the
ability to pull in stakeholders in a
setting that will drive towards
solutions so you know there's a lot of
activity in the food and beverage sector
you know again you're gonna see Gregg
tomorrow it'll talk about some of the
things that he's doing but look at the
food and beverage sector as you know
sort of the canary in the mine if you
will you know they've been at it for a
while their strategies have evolved over
time based on experiences in particular
regions or globally and they recognize
that you need to move towards the
watershed level and then they you know
they start to invest in things like the
war action hub you know anything that
can drive collective action
collaboration with stakeholders that
typically might not have come together
you know it it's just out of sheer
necessity you know
I'm using water I need to think about it
differently
so I'm just curious what is your
favorite water technology sure so I
won't technically I will tell you in
particular but I will go back to the
data piece I I think there's a lot that
can and is being done around data
acquisition remote sensing technologies
real-time monitoring of water quantity
and water quality data to drive
decision-making so I think that's a
really cool space you know five or 10
years ago you would go to a company and
ask about Carvin data and it was what
we're you know we're where's the data
where's my energy data it companies have
gotten to the point where they know how
to collect those data sets but we're now
having that conversation around water so
you know do I know how much I use in my
direct operations yeah mostly do I know
how much I use across my entire value
chain no because we've never had to use
you know look for the data set so I
think there's a lot of opportunities
there all right
and I think I owe him the two beers now
so we'll thank you very much for coming
to speak with us about this very
important topic of corporate water
stewardship thank you everybody for
coming and asking some great questions
just a plug for tomorrow at 9:30
tomorrow morning in stage 24 we're
actually going to have wri creators of
aqueduct the Army Corps and conservation
international to come talk about their
various water risk tools and
methodologies and then at 12:30
coca-cola and Intel will be in this room
talking about their own corporate water
strategies so it's gonna be really great
to have water and thanks
thank you